almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice comm slash
Pakman to download it Donald Trump's
daughter Ivanka Trump not only made a
fool out of herself holding a can of Goa
beans but appears to have broken the
same ethics rules and federal law that
Kellyanne Conway broke when she
previously promoted Ivanka Trump's
jewelry line and now Donald Trump is
also getting in on the action so let me
back up a little bit and explain the
entire thing to you now Koya foods
commonly just known as Goya is an
American company that sells food
products that are often in the Hispanic
foods aisle in grocery stores it's kind
of a weird name but not really the focus
of this segment but it's everything from
beans to frozen products flour coconut
can coconut sauces marinades etc that
Gore sells a lot of different things and
the company is owned by the UNA know a
family and they're the second richest
Spanish American family and by Spanish
now I'm talking about the country of
Spain they are a billionaire family from
from Spain the CEO Robert una Noah was
recently invited to the White House to
one of these propaganda events that
Donald Trump has been holding and the
Goya CEO said that Donald Trump is a
blessing for the United States that the
United States is blessed to have Donald
Trump as president and many people
including many Hispanic customers of
Goya products didn't like it and there
were calls for boycotts the normal
reaction outrage cycle took place Oh
everybody calling for a boycott is
suppressing the speech of Goya well this
Tuesday Ivanka Trump tweeted a picture
of herself holding a can of Goya black
beans with the message if it's Goya it
has to be good followed by a Spanish
translation csgo yeah the Innoko said
bueno or as Argentinians
say csgo Xie DNA Gossard way No so this
was just wacky she looks like a crazy
person the optics are bizarre and I
tweeted it out with the message
something is very wrong with this woman
but then it started to get more
interesting yesterday Donald Trump did
something similar posing with Goya
products in the White House including
what looked like a can of coconut
chocolate wafers beans and more and this
is a violation of federal law 5 CFR 2635
. 702 that's a mouthful it's called use
of public office for private gain and it
says an employee shall not use his
public office for his own private gain
for the endorsement of any
product/service or enterprise or for the
private gain of friends relatives or
persons with whom the employee is
affiliated in a none got non non non
governmental capacity this is the exact
same thing that Kellyanne Conway
violated when she suggested people go
out and buy Ivanka's jewelry in short
people in public office can't endorse
products in this way but that gets us to
the next level of insanity which is on
the one hand Ivanka's an advisor to
donald trump on the other hand she's not
supposed to work for Trump because of
anti-nepotism laws but on the other hand
they've gotten around this by making her
this kind of vague advisor rather than
somebody with a formal position which
she clearly would be barred from having
but she's still an administration
official of sorts but she's breaking the
law by promoting products but they can
go back to well she's really an
unofficial adviser it's a circle of
swamp it's a never-ending swamp that
gets deeper and deeper with every
passing week of this administration but
here's the deal I actually have an
optimistic message for you today I'm not
worried about this I'm not the
administration doesn't care
Trump's family doesn't care this is the
swamp filling corruption we were told
they were going to end we just have to
remove them in three and a half months
keep an eye on the bigger picture rather
than getting bogged down in individual
instances of swamp filling we know they
have to go Ivanka posing with black
beans does
change anything yes of course it's
illegal they're not going to be any
consequences
just vote them out this vote we have all
the information we need and we are
prepared to vote him out in November but
are we going to get enough turnout to do
it I hope we don't all have that
horrible feeling again on November 4th
that we had in November of 2016 I don't
want it and I'll be doing everything I
can to prevent it but you know try not
to worry too much about yet another law
breaking action we've just got to remove
them otherwise this will continue